اذا اي بعد مرور اكثر من 80 يوما على
الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه المقاومه
لا تزال قادره على اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه
اكثر من مستوطنه عند غلاف غزه في اكثر من
نقطه هذه الصواريخ تطلق بينما قطاع غزه
يعيش حاله اشتباك من شماله الى جنوبه
مرورا بالمناطق او المحافظه الوسطى
اشتباكات عنيفه ولكن الجيش الاسرائيلي
واضح ان هناك بعض الارتباك او على الاقل
هذا ما يظهر في استراتيجيه التي يستخدمها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه المعارك هو يقول
انه سيعمد الى اعتماد حرب استنزاف مع قطاع
غزه لانهاء حركه حماس وفي مرحله ثانيه
يقول انه يوسع عملياته نبدا في الابرز وهو
استمرار الاشتباكات في المنطقه الشماليه
لازالت جباليا والتفاح والشجاع
تشهد اشتباكات تصفها اسرائيل بانها تدور
على شكل حرب عصابات وحرب شوارع بينها وبين
كتائب القسام وايضا باقي فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه هذه المنطقه الاشتباكات فيها
عنيفه جدا وفي بعض الاحيان تضطر المروحيات
الاسرائيليه الى التدخل في لاستهداف بعض
المناطق قد تكون بعض الوحدات عالقه فيها
او ان ضراوه الاشتباك تعطي الكفه لصالح
المقاومه تتدخل الطائرات المروحيه و
وتنفذ ضربات محدوده ولكن ما لفت اليوم هو
حديث اسرائيلي عن انه اقترب الجيش
الاسرائيلي من تصفيه كتيبه الشجاعيه في
كتائب عز الدين القسام ويقول انها الكتيبه
الاكبر ضمن القسام ولكن بينما الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول هذه ال او يورد هذه
المعلومه بانه اقترب من القضاء على كتيبه
الشجاعيه نذكر بانه يوم امس احدى سرايا
لواء جولاني شهدت تغييرات على مستوى
القياده احد قاده الكتائب او سرايا لواء
جولاني اقيل من منصبه لانه كما قال قائد
اللواء خاطر بحياه الجنود اثناء معارك
الشجاعيه بالانتقال الى المنطقه الوسطى
ايضا المنطقه الوسطى تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه
النصيرات النصيرات والبريج يتعرضان لقصف
عنيس عنيف وهنا يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
يوسع عملياته جحر الديك لا تزال منطقه
اشتباك كبيره وهناك استهدافات للقسام
وسرايا القدس لاكثر من اليه عسكريه
والقسام فجرت فتحه نف نفق ب مجموعه من
الجنود الاسرائيليين الوضع في الجنوب ليس
اقل حده ما زالت الاشتباكات تدور يصفها
الجيش الاسرائيلي يصف ما يجري في خان يونس
بانها واحده من اكثر الاشتباكات ضراوه من
او في هذه العمليه البريه وايضا في
خانيونس هناك استهدافات لجنود وتجمعات
جنود واليات